if you were paying close attention in
the last video an interesting question
might have popped in up in your brain we
have talked about the intervals over
which the function is concave downwards
then we talked about the interval over
which the function is concave upwards
but we see here that there's a point at
which we transition from being concave
downwards to concave upwards before that
point the slope was decreasing and then
the slope starts increasing the slope
was decreasing and then the slope
started increasing so that's one way to
look at it right here in our function we
go from being concave downwards to
concave upwards when you look at our
derivative at that point our derivative
went from decreasing to increasing and
when you look at our second derivative
at that point it went from being
negative to positive so this must have
some type of a special name you're
probably thinking and you would be
thinking correctly this this point at
which we transition from being concave
downwards to concave upwards or the
point at which our derivative has an
extremum point or the point at which we
go at which our second derivative
switches signs like this we call it an
inflection point in in flexion in
flexion point and the most typical way
that people think about how could you
test for an inflection point it's a
point well conceptually it's where you
go from being a downward-opening you to
an upward-opening you or when you go
from being concave downwards to concave
upwards but the easiest test is it's a
point at which your second derivatives
which is sine so in this case we went
from negative to positive but we could
have also switched from being positive
to negative
so inflection point inflection point
your second derivative F prime prime of
X switches signs goes from being
positive to negative or negative to
positive which is sines so this is a
case where we went from concave
downwards to concave upwards if we went
from going if we went from concave
upwards to concave downwards to concave
downwards like that then this inflection
point at this inflection point up until
that point the slope was increasing so
the second
relative would be positive and then the
slope is decreasing the derivative is
decreasing so your second derivative
would be negative so here your second
derivative is going from positive to
negative here your second derivatives
going from negative to positive
in either case in either case you are
talking about an inflection point